just before the show started I was told
at one of the killer whales from
SeaWorld
which is just down the road escaped from
its enclosure SeaWorld officials are
asking us to keep an eye out for the
escaped whale they've released this
photo it's important you keep an eye on
please
be on the lookout that's just a message
I was asked to deliver all right let's
move on we got a lot to do moving on
with the show
yes hello sir I know you're late but
could you just quickly find your seat
please just find your seat
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a pretty pretty cool costume for
comic-con who are you who you supposed
to be well have you been to comic-con
before
well glad you're here tonight or you're
ready to have a good time
[Applause]
if you see any whales let us know
already got a great show tonight from
the new movie cooties and the last ones
under the large award
host of the AMC series talking dad the
Comedy Central series @midnight Chris
Hardwick
why won't you take your seat hey thanks
for watching be sure to click subscribe
to see even more great Conan clips you
may now return to your pirated movies
and creepy Japanese pornography